one of the trickier characters to play
an overwatch is Zarya she's a tank but
how does she function exactly and what's
the best way to play as the crush in
Russian Mike my hardy I took your joke
there it's Chris waters stealing jokes
but I'll give you some tips in return
let's talk about sorry Mike yeah I want
that joke back but also Zarya is a
really fun character to play if you
really can understand how her systems
work together I'm not even entirely sure
I dunno how yet but I've been playing
her a lot and they're pretty complicated
well there's a high skill ceiling but
what we're doing here in these overwatch
hero guides is giving you the basics so
here are the basics Zaria has this
particle cannon and it has two firing
ranges our modes one of them is this
short-range plasma cannon beam thing and
the other is shooting grenades those are
pretty self-explanatory yeah yeah one's
a little bit longer range if you can
figure out the arc on the grenade the
other ones pretty short range actually
it's about like 10 feet or whatever that
converts to in the game but you really
want to be up close before you use the
laser and you want to try to be accurate
because it's a very precise thing yeah
if you're chasing someone around or if
you're up close to another tank then you
turn on the beam but mostly you're going
to be slinging out those grenades they
do a little bit of area damage and
they're great for you know parrying
turrets at a distance maybe getting a
sniper off her perch but they also
because of the Splash Damage
anytime you see an enemy in group that's
what you want to use now the key parts
of this particle cannon and the key to
playing zari as a whole is her barrier
system so sorryi can shield herself and
her teammates and that's really critical
because the more damage those shields
absorbed the higher damage her attacks
are gonna do so you want to constantly
be protecting her teammates but you also
want to constantly be throwing their
shields up around herself - absolutely
and I it helps me to think of it you
know it's a shield yes and it will save
you from some damage and it will save
your teammates but it doesn't last very
long so you can't support a push on
these shields if someone's focusing down
on you it's only gonna go a little bit
of damage so I think a good way as a
beginner to think of it is these are
sponges what these do is soak up damage
the enemies are doing to you and your
teammate and you see that transferred
into the power of your weapon there are
two ways to see that visually
represented on screen so yeah there's
gonna be a number right underneath your
reticle and that's pretty much the most
obvious one but there is a cooler one in
the actual visual vocabulary of the game
the floating orb on her Tesla cannon
right above the butt of the gun will
start to get bigger so when it starts to
be this pulsating sphere that's when you
really want to unleash on your enemies
you'll also see the beam and the
grenades that you shoot out getting more
and more powerful this more raw energy
in there and it looks cool but don't get
too cocky because Zarya still needs to
be a little bit careful you know in
terms of getting overwhelmed by the
enemy team and that's a thing you want
to be around your teammates because the
more teammates are around you the more
people there are to shield and the more
people there are to you know sponge that
damage and she's really good at
shielding healers because they
themselves are pretty vulnerable so you
want to field them and that keeps them
mobile and keeps them healing you and
also shield people like tracer and
McCree who might be go off and skirmish
by themselves right before they round a
corner give them a little buff to like
kind of help them out and also give
yourself a little bit extra energy and
your projected barrier when you put onto
your allies replenishes more quickly
than your own personal barrier so you
get in a habit of using that very very
often alright now let's talk about saris
ultimate one of the most powerful
Ultimates in the game the graviton surge
the graviton surge is awesome
essentially I like to think of it as
this choke point creator if the other
enemy team is within distance of each
other or kind of within this one room or
you know ideally in an objective point
that's where they're gonna group up
shoot this mini black hole it looks like
into the group and it sucks them all in
they're not gonna be defenseless but
they're gonna be clumped up it's perfect
for your teammate playing Farah to just
start launching rockets and it's perfect
for junk rats start lobbing grenades and
it's perfect for Hanzo to fire his
dragons into there all of them like the
most combo able alt one of them in the
game and as a result it takes a long
time to charge see this is the one that
you want to communicate with your
teammates use those emotes my ultimate
is ready so that they can be queued up
but yeah again though it does do some
damage when it pulls them in they can
still fire and they can still shoot you
and you can bet they're gonna be mad at
you for putting them all in this pile
together so just be ready to take some
damage while you're dishing it out yeah
sorry is a great character both
offensively defensively for her
teammates and for herself damage and
absorbing she's a really great
all-around character and she's one of
the reasons I love this game because
it's so nuanced in so many ways so there
you have it folks
get out there absorb some damage and
deal some damage of your own as Zarya
for more overwatch hero guides keep it
tuned a game spot subscribe to our
Channel and happy over watching
you